I think that there is an anti-dating
culture at the moment okay I think that
men and women are being encouraged to be
treated as adversaries not as equals I
think it's transactional today I think
it's easy today whatever is too easy to
come you devalue it my era you had to
court you had to have scripts you had to
build relationship you had to follow
what we had Myspace the last time I was
single there was Myspace I DMD my wife
on MySpace eventually we're in Palm
Springs for the first time she's single
I'm single we go on a date there's magic
she goes home the next day I take her we
go do stairs in Santa Monica we go to
church we go to Earth Cafe in Santa
Monica then we go to borders I buy her
book on our second date called 101
questions to ask before you get engaged
on our second date she's like what's
this I said I'm not looking for a
girlfriend I'm looking for a wife I'm 28
at the time I said I know exactly what I
want I've already done this exercise
with three other girls if you want to go
through it great you need to answer the
questions let's meet up when you're
ready and let's go through it week later
6 hours at her place one by one by one
each question we go through I say this
is somebody I can date and by the way
it's ugly because you got to talk about
everything in the book that's not it
anymore